Speaker 1: Republican Congressman Adam Kinzinger
is lashing out at Republican Congresswoman
Lauren Boebert.
Remember that?
Lauren Boebert recently said, I'm sick and
tired of this separation of church and state.
It's kind of the Constitution.
Lauren But you're tired of it.
Adam Kinzinger are calling it the Christian
Taliban as a reminder.
Here is the clip from a couple of days ago.
Lauren Boebert going full throttle theocracy
saying church and state.
I'm sick of it.
Speaker 2: The reason we had so many over
reaching regulations in our nation is because
the church complied.
Speaker 1: Right.
Speaker 2: The church is supposed to direct
the government.
Why?
Government is not supposed to direct the church.
That is not how our founding fathers intended
it.
And I'm tired of the separation of church
and state junk that's not in the Constitution.
It was in a stinking letter.
And it means nothing like what they say it
does.
Speaker 1: Whoa.
Well, it turns out that that is crazy.
And fellow Republican launching a civil war
salvo from within the Republican Party, Adam
Kinzinger says, quote, There is no difference
between this.
This meaning, you know, this video of Lauren
Boebert that we just watched.
There's no difference between this and the
Taliban.
We must oppose the Christian Taliban.
I say this as a Christian.
Has a Republican politician straight up said
Christian Taliban before because they love
to talk about Sharia law.
And Oh, it's bad.
And it's going to be it's coming and.
Hold on a second.
The Christian version of Sharia law is what
has actually been plaguing this country for
a very long time.
I disagree with Adam Kinzinger politically,
but I have some respect for him now.
I know it's easier to put country over party
the way that he's doing when you're leaving.
I understand that.
I'm not naive.
I get it.
He's in a position where he doesn't care because
he's leaving.
But it is amazing how the bar has been lowered.
Democrats today would be thrilled to some
degree to deal with the Republicans from 15
years ago.
Not that those were good people.
We shouldn't see them as good people, but
15 years ago the Republicans were much more
reasonable to deal with.
That being said, the Republicans are 15 years
ago are responsible for the Republican Party
today being what it is.
And what I mean by that is they didn't condemn
the start of the rhetoric that led to Trumpism
today.
They didn't condemn the extremism.
They didn't say, well, we've got to stop this
here or here or here.
They allowed it to keep going.
So while I would much rather be dealing with
the Republicans of 15 years ago than people
like Lauren Boebert, that's for sure.
We also have to understand the historical
context which I talked about with many people,
including Noam Chomsky on the show before,
that they are also responsible for what we
are seeing today.
But to the extent that Adam Kinzinger is willing
to call it out, to the extent that Adam Kinzinger
is maybe going to change some Republicans
mind and get some Republicans to go, hey,
you know what, the boebert version of Republicanism
is crazy.
It's not even constitutional.
Tired of separation of church and state.
It's like being tired of the First Amendment.
Lauren Which I thought you cared about to
the extent that he might have an impact on
anybody.
I gladly welcome Adam Kinzinger, his comments